it's 8:00 in the morning after a cold
night on the Greek island of Lesbos even
making a cup of tea is a logistical
challenge for our net armed Ajit the
Iraqi and his friends have run out of
firewood
they'll have to burn a cardboard box
instead Ahmed has been stuck here for
two months in an illegal camp near the
Moria refugee camp we don't have a
bathroom we don't have a water for
washing for swimming you know so we have
many many many refugees sick but we
don't have a medicine here for emergency
lesbaz official refugee camp Moria is
located nearby it resembles a
high-security prison the camp was set up
to keep migrants on the island until
their applications for asylum can be
processed it's forbidden to film here
and journalists aren't allowed in either
but Ahmed wants to show us what really
goes on in the camp we follow him in and
film using a hidden camera
here it smells of smoke garbage and
human waste the United Nations refugee
agency described Moria as dangerous for
children and pregnant women and yet they
are the ones left languishing in the
camp many have been stuck here for
months because it is getting colder many
simply set fire to old olive trees to
keep warm but these trees belong to this
man stelios kathy otis he struggles to
remain calm while surveying the
devastation this olive grove has been in
his family for generations some trees
are up to 300 years old and he's devoted
his life to cultivating them but now
little remains all these trees are burnt
all burnt there's nothing left these
trees will not grow back they're
finished there were 120 trees and
there's only four left and no one cares
neither to compensate us nor to stop
them every night they cut the trees and
burn them stelios shows us the hole in
the fence they used to go in and out all
of his attempts to press charges against
the refugees have proven unsuccessful
that's likely why they continue to kill
his sheep
the last ones here even left their tools
behind the farmer tells us he's kept
them as evidence a backpack from the
United Nations refugee agency and a
knife he says this is clear proof that
refugees are to blame and he has a
fairly good idea why the refugees kill
his sheep they're not stealing because
they're hungry they kill the animals and
they sell them one or two people can't
eat 7 or 10 sheep as we found out they
sell them to other refugees I've seen
people in the fields grilling the meat
on campfires yes caption andreas the
village of Moria lives as if in a state
of siege stelios and the other villagers
meaty irregularly to discuss what action
they might take to end the crisis the
village council head Niko's truck
Haleigh's has just returned from Athens
he reports on his talks with the Greek
authorities he doesn't have much
positive news if the situation goes on
like this it won't take long before we
have physical confrontation up to now
we've tolerated the looting of people's
assets and it's fortunate that things
haven't become violent but it's only a
question of time before this happens his
making of them
ahmed al Majid fled from the violence in
his Iraqi homeland he doesn't want to be
equated with lawbreakers he just wants
to leave lesbos but right now boarding a
ferry to Athens is something he can only
dream of I waiting a decision like
another refugees they waiting for eight
months ago they don't to trouble they
don't let him they don't let us the
trouble so so we're planning to escape
from the side he's still thinking about
it but others are making concrete plans
every evening people try to get through
the fence and reach the ferry unnoticed
for many it's the only way to leave the
Greek island which has become their
prison
you